CBS this morning is partnered with the
professional networking site LinkedIn
for our continuing series
work-in-progress which explores the
future of the American workforce this
morning we are looking at employers use
of high-tech wellness programs to keep
track of workers nutrition exercise and
sleep about 6 million employees
worldwide reportedly receive a fitness
tracker is a part of work wellness
programs last year that's an increase of
about four million in two years twenty
one percent of large companies that
offer health insurance collected data
from those wearable devices in 2018 the
previous year it was 14 percent
according to a Kaiser Family Foundation
survey survey jesse hempel is linked in
senior editor at large
good morning Jesse good morning thanks
for having me so what are companies
trying to accomplish with these devices
well companies have two goals right and
the first is not a surprise at all they
want to save money and they know that if
people are healthier they will cost less
over time through health insurance but
also this is a new trendy thing that you
can offer employees that employees are
asking for and so they want to be able
to offer it and it's not hard to do and
some of the incentives are worthwhile
right oh yeah I mean there was one
company in Texas that the Washington
Post reported on last week where you
could you could earn as much as a
thousand dollars back over the course of
a year and that's a lot of money to the
average American worker and are any of
the workers penalized in a sort of
carrot sticks an area where they may get
a lot of incentives if they do actually
workout but if they don't what happens
well that's a great question and you
know for the most part these programs
are opt-in you choose and you are
rewarded when the question of penalty
comes up employee is sent to react very
badly to that literal carrots and sticks
if you eat a lot of carrots you won't
get the stick what exactly are you
opting into though with respect to
sharing your data and how much of it
with your employer that is exactly the
question that every viewer needs to ask
before they sign up for one of these
programs because here's the thing they
are all different right now there isn't
sort of one out of the box program now
most of them are offered through a
health insurer somebody like Aetna which
last month signed a big contract with
Apple for example to roll out one of
these programs and when that's the case
hip
for the most part if you're getting a
fitness tracker through your health
insurer HIPPA is going to mean that your
health insurer is not going to pass that
information back to your employer but if
that health tracker is coming through a
company that is not a health care
company that question is still up in the
air we don't know so what are you gonna
law that hip is the law of Ed regulates
what kind of private information can be
exactly Jones so what are some of the
questions that employees should be
asking employers before they sign up
well there is really only one question
and you've got to keep it front and
center and that is who gets to see my
data and by extension like how can they
use my data and this this is an
interesting one and it comes up with
every tech device because there is a
short term answer to that question and
then there are these long term
unintended consequences and it is up to
everybody who makes a choice to use one
of these to decide the balance for her
or himself in the short term this might
be great
maybe your information is protected by
HIPAA as we were talking about and you
have the sense that you are in control
of in your information but none of us
can guarantee that things aren't going
to change in the future that federal
regulation isn't going to change that
what is allowed to be shared isn't going
to change and you have to be comfortable
with whatever happens or that employees
the employers begin to mandate that you
share your health data with them before
you can get insurance or the type of
insurance that they pay for that's
that's exactly right and you know it's a
question that people are talking about a
ton and so you know I see this actually
come up a lot on LinkedIn and we asked
we asked people recently whether they
thought these Fitness truckers were a
good idea and frankly the answer was
kind of mixed like straight down the
middle there are a group of people who
are just concerned about privacy and
others who are like yeah that's the
great benefit the future Jessie head
poll thank you so much thank you